like to iron i know that's kind of a  blast from the past but you can do super  quick little laundry ironing if you have  a built-in ironing board so i have a  built-in ironing board here i'm tall so  i installed it nice and tall makes me  really happy and my ironing board or my  iron is here with my plug-in again it  was just planning there's nothing really  expensive about this but installing it  now i did have a little problem because  our house is made of concrete so i had  to mount it on the wall that was a  little problem um  but then i have that there i also  installed  a retractable clothesline so that we  have lots of bras in our house because  there's lots of  athletes i have the hook hidden right  behind this little thing and i can hang  all of my bras up there just like that  pretty special